extremely fragile and dangerous that's
how the chief of the un's nuclear
Watchdog has described the situation of
the zaparisian nuclear plant in Ukraine
Raphael Grossi fears increased fighting
around the facility could lead to a
nuclear accident and he's laid out plans
to the U.N security Council on ways to
keep it safe Kristen salumi reports
the head of the international atomic
energy agency presented his plan to
avoid the release of radioactive
materials from the zafaresia nuclear
power plant to a divided Security
Council
plant Europe's largest has been under
Russian control since March of last year
but primarily staffed by Ukrainian
technicians Grossi called for no attacks
to be launched from or against the plant
and said it should not be used as a
storage base for heavy weapons or troops
he also said the plant's one source of
power crucial to preventing fuel rods
from overheating had to be protected
Russia for its part accused Ukraine of
shelling the plants
the plant has never seen any heavy
weapons or its ammunitions placed on its
territory nor is there any military
personnel present at the power plant
that could be used to carry out an
attack from the facility while Ukraine
and its Western allies said Russia had
no right to be there in the first place
these principles must be complemented
with the demand of full demilitarization
and the occupation of the station the
security Council took no action on
grossi's plan and neither Russia nor
Ukraine directly endorsed it each blame
the other for putting zafarisha at risk
but Grossi said he had engaged with
officials from both countries at the
highest levels the important thing is
that the minimum common denominator
which are this
basic five principles have been
widely supported and there was no voice
opposing them this is very important
this indicates that what we are saying
is something no one has a contradictory
View and he vowed his team on site will
continue monitoring the plan for
adherence to these principles Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera the United Nations
a fire broke out an oil refinery in
southern Russia the local Governor says
it's likely been hit by a drone attack
it comes after Moscow saw several drone
strikes on residential buildings on
Tuesday Russia's accused Ukraine of
terrorist activity Barbara angopa
reports
for some this was the moment Russia's
war in Ukraine hit home
residents in the wealthy suburb west of
Moscow were working to a large-scale
drone attack
Russian President Vladimir Putin said it
was an attempt to terrify Russians after
Moscow hit strategic sites in Ukraine
[Music]
as you know the key of regime has chosen
a different path the path of attempts to
intimidate Russia and its citizens and
Strikes on residential buildings this is
of course a clear sign of terrorist
activities
Russia says eight drones were launched
in the attack but it was able to shoot
down five and disable three
moscow's mayor says there's some minor
damage but no one was seriously hurt
s
regime has crossed all boundaries I
would like to see some work by our
authorities to find the people who
launched the drones because they are
here clearly these drones did not come
from Ukraine
investigators say they'll find out who
sent them and from where
the emergency services are working on
the ground investigators and forensic
experts are also there the perpetrators
of this crime will be identified
Ukraine's been preparing a
counter-offensive against Russia for
months but it's denied any involvement
in the Drone attacks Barbara angopa Al
Jazeera